when you love something you fight for it
we're the ones who changed everything
happy tuesday everybody welcome to et
canada nerd alert for our very first
round table we're going to be inviting
some of uh the biggest fandom nerds help
us break down the latest trending
new news i'm carlos bustamante joining
me today is jeff
johnson uh nerd and pop culture
commentator and eli glasner
senior entertainment and senior
entertainment reporter and film critic
at cbc now we have a lot to talk about
i want to talk about mcu's phase four
okay that trailer just dropped
last week and i don't know how many
times y'all watched it i watched it no
less than six times
and it wasn't it wasn't for any sort of
like i want to get
the easter eggs and all that it was just
to feel something
it was just to feel something again man
when they showed the clip of the
audience
in theater the avengers assemble moment
i was very nearly brought to tears just
watching it on my laptop
on your left
i know that we're all enjoying these
previous tv shows from home
it's lovely to be able to sit on our
couch but for both of you are you
excited
to have that feeling again with a crowd
of people or does it still make you
a little nervous if you think we're
gonna get back there uh jeff start with
you
yeah i i i would be lying
and carlos you're my friend so i will
not lie to you um
uh i am a little nervous about going
back
you know we're still in the middle of
pandemic regardless of what outside is
telling you
we're still in the middle of a pandemic
and it it's starting to subside but it's
not all the way so
while i i do miss that
feeling of experiencing a moment in the
theater for the first time
with strangers and people you don't even
know
and having the same reaction and those
type of
indelible feelings that'll last a
lifetime the pandemic is always going to
be in the back of my mind i'm sure
towards the end as we go on
i'll get more and more comfortable and
that mcu
release did not help
it uh pushing me towards the side of the
theaters because it's just like damn
one after another after another at some
point i'm gonna make my return but
i i do miss having that feeling in the
theater especially with
a whole bunch of nerds in the audience
to geek out to what we see on screen
yeah with those dates released next to
all the titles it was almost like
picking and choosing which one
of these movies you think you'll
actually be able to get that experience
with
because like you know it's going to be a
bit down the line
what are your thoughts on that yeah i
mean i think the thing is
i'm torn right like i love that
experience i love
being in the dark i can still remember
the sound of that
roar from some of those avengers
end game moment i want to have that
again i miss it dearly it's not the same
watching these movies or series with my
cat
on the couch right so i i long for it
but i have to feel comfortable i want to
be in that theater and i don't want to
be looking at the fan next to me i don't
want to be trying to cheer through my
math
i really want to just be back to where
we used to be
and so you know those trailers they say
only in theaters
it might take me a little while to get
back there maybe not as soon
as you know that the disney machine
wants but i am
looking forward to that return whenever
it comes
so maybe in the meantime we can all sort
of be settled with
kind of co-watching online together
and then maybe like recording your zoom
screen when we all get to cheer at that
moment who knows
i don't know that'll be the new version
of that right all right
so i know that on investor day we saw a
lot of the news of what these releases
were going to be
but even still this trailer gave us like
the official titles and release dates
for certain things
and even with that for people that are
paying attention you know you know those
those can give us clues and exciting
hints as to what these films are going
to be about
i want to know from you guys what
surprised you most
when you saw that trailer last week jeff
surprise are we even surprised anymore
what marvel does they just their
marketing team
they they know how to make a trailer
they've innovated the way trailers are
made
to to make the audience expect
to see something off the hook when they
when they drop
and now they don't even have to tell us
they they've beyonce the game with the
trailers where
we don't get a heads up we don't get a
teasers here it is
enjoy so i don't know if too many things
shock me about them anymore but what i
will say
is the end of the trailer when they had
the four
the fantastic four logo where some
people like oh they're talking about
phase four i'm like no look deeper
look deeper look into the blue oasis and
see
connect the dots and witness that
they're telling you
it's coming right so then so then you
get into your always sunny mode and you
start putting everything on the
on the board and connecting the dots to
see where could it fit in
now that could be to me that could be
either the end of phase four
or the transition to phase five
so when i look at all the movies that
are being released i'm trying to figure
out
where could this fit and honestly
because of the fantastic four
and their ties to the multiverse and
their ties to space and their ties to
science
they literally could go anywhere so
while the guest may be it's coming after
all those movies
it may fit in somewhere before
well all we have to do is look as you
know as recently as one division
for people to be talking about like well
this has got to be the you know the
richards family have got to be in here
and they're not but people are still
holding out hope eli there's something
funny about the
sort of parallel nature of the world
building
of the mcu and also the behind the
scenes
world building so to speak of like how
we're gonna get these characters
in everybody knows right that pays
attention
they know about the what they think they
know about the conversations that are
going on
what they hope is gonna happen um
you know what are your what's your take
what are your thoughts about the
fantastic
four in phase four you mean you mean
this
this team yeah
um so i can't wait
very excited clobbering time you know
marvel's first
family i think we need you know our mr
fantastic our invisible woman
you know our thing our hot head uh human
torch
i actually enjoyed the first iteration
the 2005 film i will stand by it great
chris evans uh human torch performance i
i think
i think jeff's right i think that's
exactly what they're teasing i could see
where it
fits in a number of places i could see
them bumping into them
somewhere out in space regarding the
galaxy three i'm
actually surprised carlos that they're
waiting that long like it's such a big
property
and i think one of the things that they
have accomplished now with the mcu
they have actually brought comic book
continuity
to the big screen like the fact that
we're now in this world
where it's this like mosaic of
storytelling that's
built on by artists and screenwriters
and call backs across like years and
decades on your left little bits and
pieces
that they're like it's like planting
eggs and other easter eggs and other
little pieces
and slowly it's coming together like
even if you look at like
harry potter we've never had such a rich
fabric of this like shared
fantasy sci-fi world and now it seems
like with phase four
they're even going further weirder and
stranger in so many great ways the thing
that i was most excited about
was the marvels the new marbles movie
right so not captain marvel 2.
amazing that the leaks from that series
look fantastic
first muslim superhero for marvel and
then you know the woman that she looked
up to
joining forces with captain marvel i
you know i had some issues with the
first captain marvel movie
but to see those marvels together
so good cannot wait i think that's it's
you touched on something there that's
really interesting this the shorthand
for fans
that kind of understand what could be
coming
so even in just the way that they phrase
the titles the marvels without saying
anything eli you understood okay they're
going to bring this character in and
this character in
monica rambo will probably be part of it
and there's now there's going to be all
this excitement around
all the stuff that for people that have
followed the stories for decades and
decades
it's sort of paying off one of the
coolest things that i
encountered over the past break when we
were watching you know uh falcon and
soldier and one division was my in-laws
saying okay so we're gonna start one
division
so carlos what do i need to like almost
like it's like almost like talking about
back issues right
like oh you should read this issue this
issue okay watch
this movie that this movie and you can
kind of help connect the dots for people
i think that's a really cool thing
so marvel's gonna be amazing jeff what
movie
were you looking at going this is the
one that i want to see the most
that's like asking my my that's asking
your parent their favorite kid right
he's like i have one but they're all
equal i don't love even uh all of them
equally um i'm gonna say
well you look behind me and you already
know where my my allegiance lies
with the spider universe so that's like
a given for me that um uh
no way home is something that i've been
waiting for because if it's spider-man
i'm i'm i'm on it
but i would say i'm most fascinated by
shang chi because the mcu is going to
take on
kung fu flick genre which if you have
any type of eclectic exquisite taste
if you have any coop you love movies
right so now we're gonna take one of the
most underrated characters
in marvel the man with hands
shang chi and we're gonna put him in a
universe where they're going to build a
kung fu flick
i can only i can't even fathom what
they're going
to do with it but i hope they dive full
into it they go they they take off the
safety belt
and go full kung fu flick with it
because you also have
the mandarin lurking because if you
listen the legend of the ten rings
once again for the comic fans you know
that means the mandarin and i'm i'm
really really mandarin yes yes
right right not not not the best
not the thespian mandarin playing one on
tv
but the actual mandarin and you know
there is also
has been concerns because of the
stereotypical nature of what the
mandarin was in the comics
so how are they going to flip it to make
him a powerful character
sans stereotypes and actually somebody
that
the the fans will embrace because you
know
i love the fact that they're not killing
their villains now
and we're actually getting them to to to
stay around and build more in the world
because just like eli said these are
visual graphic novels
that were seen and this phase
is is interesting because now we're
getting more of the solo book
aspect of the phases everybody's in
their own world handling stuff
but we don't know what's going to bring
them all back together
because this is a new world now the
original avengers
are pretty much gone so what's going to
be the calamity that brings them all
together
and i'm excited to say i don't know what
it is i can guess
but i don't know what it is yet what's
cool about where they're at in phase
four now and you guys both
alluded to it earlier is that all the
stops are off now
so we've got outer space we've got the
multiverse coming
like this is the most comic book that
comic book movies
have ever been and you know they kind of
had to ease the audience into it with
the visual language
and kind of being being grounded in like
real world stuff like the ultimate style
of miller style of
you know um uh storytelling now we can
scare the newbies at the beginning
yes yes and and so now we can say oh
yeah
there's a there's a full multiverse out
there and how do we think
and this is a real question to you guys
that the idea of this multiverse
is gonna kind of affect the stories
moving forward with
you know we got the venom trailer
already venom 2
and i i was delighted by what it looked
like i was not the biggest fan of the
first movie but this trailer looked
really promising to me
but with some of the easter eggs in
there like the you know the way that
they wrote the daily bugle on the daily
bugle newspaper
that's the least trick for someone who
liked the raymond movies and the talk
about how spider-man is not really
involved
is kind of involved but they don't know
about them but like do we really think
that this is
this is multiversal storytelling and
that's how we're going to bring all
these other
properties into the mcu together we
leave behind
and how do we leave them
waiting in the darkness of the rescuer
who never
comes not quite
there's one dimension that
can't be bridged and that's the
corporate dimension
like sony and disney can only go
so far and so i think we're gonna see
as many properties that you know the
venomverse
and the spidey verse that sony can get
its hands on
um but i i i don't
i'd be even surprised we see our tom
holland i think they're going to leave
kind of venom alone
to do his thing they're going to build
out that world we're going to see other
kind of spider
characters more villains and whatnot
but i i you know i can't really see a
true crossover coming and i think i
think what i like about the venom movie
so far
and i think the first one was kind of
slept on is like like the
spider-man movies tom holland and all of
that like it's like bright it's colorful
it's like a john hughes movie and that's
great like it's got its own personality
venom movies it kind of it's kind of
grungy
and a little it's a different sort of
vibe and i think to bring too much of
the rest of marble in it
would actually ruin what works
about the venom film so i'm i'm excited
to see where it's going
i like the new trailer but i i i'm not
expecting too much of of a cross over
there
well that's the thing about grunge right
it's usually dirtying and
mucking something up and when you clear
it off you see what it really is
and i see what venom in that series
really is and i'm
not impressed they got they have
a clintarin speaking like a cross
between the tasmanian devil
and uh the venus fly trap from little
shop of horrors
i love them
if i was sony i would be chomping at the
bit to get into the multiverse because
that means
multi millions and billions but if i
marvel
i don't touch venom with sonics i don't
touch venom with fire
and i don't touch venom with a 10-foot
pole because as much as i love tom hop
how um i do love tom holland but as much
as i love tom hardy and much i love
woody harrelson and the things that they
do
i wasn't feeling that trailer at all i
felt like the worst parts of the 90s
were back
in the way that they are portraying
these characters now i feel like
there's even better characters in the
spider-verse that they can take from
um i just don't think that i don't think
that any characters in the mc right now
benefit
or marvel at disney in general benefit
from having
venom and carnage in their universe
i think that sony and venom need need
marvel and spider-man a lot more than
than you know they need venom shoot i do
too i got bills eli
i need them too like you know i would be
right there with you
yes so with that said guys you know
the avengers not being the present that
they've been
you've got a bit of a clean slate this
is what i want to leave you guys with
this question here
we don't have uh steve tony we i mean we
still have thor
loving thunder is going to be amazing i
don't know if you disagree with me
i don't know if we could it would be
amazing all that said
we had a clean say we know that the
eternals are coming but we don't know
much about them
guardians of the galaxy is gonna be
great fantastic four we don't know
what's going on
who is carrying the torch from phase
four moving forward it's been avengers
avengers avengers up until this point
is there a team or a character that we
think is going to be
the central point of the stories moving
forward
i think it's the eternals i think the
eternals are the new avengers
because i think the eternals are marvel
realizing there were things that they
didn't really cover in their first place
they were taking it slow they were
playing with all your favorite original
toys
and you didn't have a lot of diversity
you didn't have a lot of representation
and the eternals is a major corrective
we've got major representation we have
gay
superheroes we have deaf superheroes we
have
so many cultures and creatures and
everything there
and again it seems like new kind of
heroes
new kind of abilities we're talking a
story that spans like
a millennia you've got an oscar-winning
director chloe zhao
behind the scenes and so like
i i you know who's gonna be the next
avengers is a fascinating question
but if you wanted to reinvent the
avengers
for the next phase for the next decade
i think the eternals is a great place to
start so if they can stick that landing
if it delivers
on that promise i think that sets the
tone
for the new phase
jeff what do you think that's a that's a
great take that's a that's a dope taking
like i wasn't even thinking on that
on that road i'll go a little bit more
out of box conventional um
we're seeing the early seeds of the
champions
kamala khan is coming iron heart
williams is coming right and isaiah
that was in falcon in the winter soldier
he
we don't know if he has powers or if he
doesn't have powers
but he could be in the mix too so i
think
while whatever is coming next the the
next torchbearers the future
is being built now tell people what the
champions are for those who don't know
oh yeah so the champions if you're
familiar with the teen titans
who are the the young superheroes in dc
the champions are now they're they're
newer
but they're like the young teenage
heroes similar to
the young avengers or the young x-men
you know it's like you if you're 18 and
below you're considered
young right you're like the next teenage
hero so this has been a
original original team that was built
from some of the
the um the mantle wearers the future
mantle where is like
miles is a part of the team uh riri
you have the the young young wasp you
have bombshell who's who was a villain
a reformed villain turned turned hero so
it's like if all your friends if it's
like
your high school was full of super
powered people and you eventually
some people you had beef with and some
people you did it you knew from other
classes and you all got together
that would be the champions so i would
say definitely keep a lookout for that
but i do see them building the new
avengers too
because you got sam sam who's captain
america now
you know thor is still around he's in
space or whatever but
he's still be that's still being built
shang chi is
is coming now so it's like you have a
lot of people who are starting to
establish themselves like ant-man is
around now
you know and the wasps are around now so
you have people that are starting to
establish themselves
who are gonna be on the front lines
whenever that
new threat arises and we've seen those
seeds being planted in the series as
well
so many people talking about wanda's
kids um
and you know with kate bishop hawkeye
on board and we've got we got to think
about you know
even though we you know we're not
bridging that corporate multiverse like
you said
eli but we do have uh a potential of a
real life miles morales
sometime down the line so what i think
you know i love elastic i love your take
too jeff
i think there are so many different ways
that they can go with who's
going to be central it just kind of
becomes a matter of pivoting
to who who's really sticking thanks
again gentlemen there's been et cancer
alert
join us for more videos right here
online and we're going to be back with
you guys
when uh loki starts that's that's the
next big one
so we'll see you then
you